bonsoir Jean-Louis bourlange bonsoir
vous êtes député MoDem des des hautes
scè président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de l'Assemblée
nationale etmanuel Macron a dit
aujourd'hui sa solidarité pleine et
entière avec Israël le Premier ministre
israélien Benjamin netaniahou a dit nous
sommes en guerre est-ce que ça veut dire
que la France soutient cette guerre là
la nous sommes effectivement totalement
solidaires du peuple
israélien nous sommes totalement enfin
personnellement moi en tout cas mais je
crois que la plupart de mes cèes èg
sinon la totalité de mes collègues
sommes absolument horrifiés par le le
les actes terroristes qui ont été menés
par le haramas exactement dans les
termes qu'employait le grand Rabin à
l'instant la la l'attaque sur des civils
la prise d'otage l'humiliation
l'incarcération et disons le mot la
déportation d'enfants d'enfants des des
innocents absolus qui sont emmenés en en
en en dans dans le territoire de de dans
la bande de Gaza et qui serviront de
monnaie d'échange ou seront
massacrés la la violence la la rêve
parti qui est une sorte de
bataaclan de de Bataclan israélien tout
ça soulève une profonde indignation et
une condamnation je crois qu'aucune
cause politique aucune cause politique
même celle du peuple palestinien ne peut
justifier le recours au terrorisme et le
recours à cette ce déferlement absolu de
brutalité Jean-Lou borangeche face à ce
que vous décrivez et que peu de gens
contestent se pose la question des
modalité de la réponse israélienne droit
d'Israël à se défendre effectivement
communément admis est-ce que c'est y
compris comme l' dit ministre israélien
de la Défense en coupant le gaz l'eau la
nourriture et l'électricité à plus de 2
millions de Gazaoui si vous me permettez
je voulais ajouter quelque chose avant
de répondre à votre question c'est
qu'effectivement la situation de
désespoir certainement pas une
manifestation aussi violente nous la
voyons venir moi nous l'avons VO venir
au cours des mois précédents nous avons
bien vu que la situation politique créée
par l'interruption du processus de paix
la radicalisation de part et d'autrre
les mesures prises par le
gouvernement israélien crée une
situation dans lequelle il n'y avait
plus d'avenir il n'y a pas d'avenir pour
le peuple le peuple palestinien je crois
que nous sommes moi je suis de ceux
vieux disciple de Rabine je trouve que
la solution des deux états était la
seule elle est abandonné elle a été
clairement abandonnée et elle n'a pas
été
remplacée vous êtes comme beaucoup un
orphelin des accords non mais je suis un
orphelin je suis je crois que on aurait
d on pouvait imaginer d'autres solutions
que les deux États mais rien n'a été
proposé et ça je crois qu'on a donc créé
une situation alors moi je le dis très
clairement
expliquer ne justifie pas c'est pas
parce qu'on explique une situation de
d'unasse dans lequel l'ensemble de des
des des populations d'Israël et de
Palestine s'était placé qu'on doit le
moins du monde justifier cautionner ce
qui s'est passé maintenant je vous
répond je vous répond à votre question
excusez-moi alors moi je je je
m'interroge qu'est-ce que je ferais
parce que c'est comme ça qu'un homme
politique réagit qu'est-ce que je ferais
si j'étais le premier ministre le chef
du gouvernement israélien à vrai dire je
ne vois pas quelles sont réellement ces
options son premier souci doit être à
mon avis de sauver la vie des otages
d'abord le premier souci c'est de
protéger Israël de rétablir sa
souveraineté de rétablir son territoire
ça je crois que c'est pratiquement fait
ça s'en est occupé deuxièmement il
s'agit effectivement de récupérer ces
ces ces jeunes ces personnes ces femmes
ces enfants qui ont été pris en et je
crois que c'est c'est très très
difficile alors au-delà de ça que
peut-il faire vous posez une très bonne
question est-ce que le fait qui est une
mesure de de de représaille en réalité
d'enfermer la zone de Gaza et
d'interdire son ravitaillement en eau
alors ça débouche sur quoi est-ce que ça
débouche sur la disparition de ces 2
millions un peu plus de 2 millions de
personnes qui sont à Gaza je ne pense
pas que ce type de solution soit
satisfaisante ou envisageable il s'agit
simplement de trouver une
solution qui soit opérationnel et
raisonnable est-ce que le Israël voudra
pour porter on a comparé avec le 11
septembre c'est intéressant cette
comparaison parce que le 11 septembre a
entraîné les Américains à avoir une
surréaction particulièrement
catastrophique avec l'invasion de l'Irak
là est-ce qu'on veut est-ce que israël
va porter la guerre en en Liban je ne le
crois pas car je crois que ce serait
très Dang est-ce que au-delà il
porterait la guerre en Iran voyez qu'on
est à la menace à la dans le risque d'un
embrasement géndéral et je pense que là
les puissances les les Américains les
Russes après tout qui doivent jouer un
rôle làdedans il sont bien avec tout le
monde les Russes ils sont bien avec ils
sont bien avec netanahou ils sont ils
sont évidemment bien avec l'Iran et
cetera ils pourrait jouer un rôle en
plus ça changerait de l'Ukraine et nous
la France est-ce qu'on a encore une
quelconque influence au Pr nous nous
somes totalement solidaire de de de
d'Israël dans son droit à la sécurité
son son son son droit
à à à vivre en paix mais que pour on
peut agir si le Conseil de sécurité agit
c'est possible le Conseil de sécurité
pourrait enfin sortir de sa léthargie
sortir de ses divisions là peut-être
enfin il y aurait-il une occasion pour
lui parce qu'après tout Israël a été
créé par le Conseil de sécurité par
l'ensemble de l'assemblée générale des
Nations unies mais a été porté sur les
fonds btismaux si j'ose cette métaphore
religieuse assez approximative il a été
il a été porté par les États-Unis les
Européens et et et l'Union soviétique à
l'époque donc peut-être les puissance
doivent s'engager nous avons
collectivement le devoir d'éviter un
embrasement général Jean-Louis borlange
il nous reste une minute on l'a évoqué
tout à l'heure avec RAIM corcia
l'attitude de la France insoumise la
première ministre a dénoncé des
ambiguités révoltantes est-ce que vous
dites la même chose est-ce que vous avez
le sentiment comme on dit que le LFI est
sorti ou ressorti de l'Arque républicain
écoutez je crois qu'il y a eu parmi moi
je ne vais pas porter de jugement sur
globalement sur des déclarations de
plusieurs collègues je crois qu'elles
n'ont pas été les mêmes selon selon les
collègues je remarquerai une chose c'est
que Monsieur Mélenchon a appelé à la
Concorde a appelé à la résorption
des des luttes donc je pense qu'il a
fait il a pris sur ce point l'exacte
contrepied de ce qui est son discours
ordinaire qui est un appel à la
conflictualité générale B moi je suis
effectivement pour la Concorde et je
suis contre la conflictualité et je
crois que nous avons le devoir le devoir
premièrement de faire baisser la tension
deuxièmement d'éviter un embrasement
plus général et troisièmement de dégager
une solution qui permette aux
Palestiniens qui sont les grands oubliés
des 30 dernières années d'avoir une vie
collective normale voilà ce que je je
crois et en tout cas moi je par rapport
à quiconque je ne cautionne en rien ni
de près ni de loin la fin ne justifie
pas les moyens je ne cautionne en rien
ce déferlement abominable de violence
nous sommes solidaire du peuple
israélien de sa souffrance et de ses
malheurs merci beaucoup d'être venu le
dire ce soir sur le plateau du 1920 de
France Info Jean-Louis bourlange
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères de l'Assemblée nationale et
Merci à VOUS Gill Bornstein